الفصول الثلاثه في السعوديه قرار وقر في
السادس والعشرين من مايو الزم من خلاله
التعليم العام في موت حل الجامعات حريه
الاختيار الامر الذي اعلنت من خلاله سبع
جامعات سعوديه عوده النظام الى الفصلين
الدراسيين في عام الدراسي المقبل
[موسيقى]
ضميرنا من الرياض المستشار التربوي
والتعليمي عبد اللطيف الحمادي سيدي عبد
اللطيف حياك الله معي في نشره الرابع سبع
جامعات كبرى في السعوديه تقرر العوده الى
نظام الفصلين
هل يعني ان هذه الجامعات تعلن ان هذا
النظام نظام الثلاثه فصول فاشل او غير جيد
بالنسبه له
طبعا في البدايه حقيقه نثمن الدعم
اللامحدود حقيقه للتعليم وما وصل اليه
التعليم لدينا من الجامعات او على مستوى
التعليم العام من امكانيات كبيره وقفزه
يعني على مستوى العالم في تصنيف العالمي
بالنسبه للتحول الجامعات حقيقه وزاره
التعليم اصدرت هذا القرار واعطت
الحريه للجامعات في اختيار الفصول
الدراسيه فمثل ما ذكرتم بتقريركم هناك سبع
جامعات انا اعتقد انه اغلب الجامعات في
السعوديه راح ترجع الى
الفصول الدراسيه الفصلين دراسيين نظرا
لوجه التحدي في السنوات الماضيه السنوات
السنتين الماضيتين الجامعات واجهه التحدي
كبير في نظام الفصول الدراسيه الثلاثه لم
تستطع يعني
اكمال مثلا عندنا فتره الفصل الفصل الصيفي
صار في اشكاليه التدريب والاتصال العلمي
للاسات اذا صار في اشكاليه مشكله
تقليل المشاريع التطبيقيه ايضا الخطط
الجامعيه واعت مادها يعني معروف ان الخطط
الج معتمده مثلا فصلين كان في السابق الان
تم تغييرها الى ثلاث فصول عدد الساعات بعض
الجامعات اضطرت انها ترفع عدد الساعات
لبعض المقررات وهذه سبب اشكاليه كبيره
حقيقه
من المتوقع ان ترجع جميع الجامعات
السعوديه الى الفاصلين الدراسيين
الاجود اكاديميه الان بالنسبه للجامعه
طبعا الجامعات لديها خطط يعني الجامعات كل
جامعه
وخطط في في تنفيذها فكان الانسب يعني
للجامعات طبعا وزاره التعليم استفدت يعني
وضعت استفتاء للجامعات في في فيما يناسبها
فكان فكان الجميع اغلبهم يؤيد النظامين
نظام الفصلين الدراسيين نظرا مثل ما ذكرت
امكانيه يعني اتاحه فرصه للفصل الدراسي
فصل الصيفي تدريب والاتصال بالنسبه للاسات
الجامعه المشاريع التطبيقيه ايضا اعتماد
الخطط فما في شكل الفصلين الدراسي
للجامعات هو اجود
وارتب لنظامها بينما يبقى التعليم العام
على ثلاث فصول دراسيه طيب هل سيكون هناك
تاثير على الطلاب الزائرين على على نقل
الطلاب خاصه انه في فرق بين جامعه وبين
اخرى يعني هل سيكون هناك تاثر باختلاف هذه
التعاونات يعني او هذه طبعا
مجلس شؤون الجامعات اصدر قرارات حقيقه غير
مسبوقه ومهمه جدا في تنظيم العمل بين
الجامعات والطلاب لذلك الان اصبح للطالب
الزائر بامكانه
الالتحاق باي جامعه اخرى سعوديه لدينا
27 جامعه سعوديه يستطيع ان يرتق فيها
ويدرس تلم صيفي وايضا يحسب تحسب المقررات
ضمن المعدل التراكمي في السابق لا تحسب
الان مع النظام الجديد نظام مجلس الشؤون
الجامعات اتاح احتساب مقررات الطالب
الزائر ضمن المعدل التراكمي هل بيكون في
عندنا اشكاليه او اختلاف الان بين نظام
التعليم العادي اللي يقر ثلاثه فصول وهو
نظام التعليم الجامعي اللي شفنا في سبع
جامعات تعود الى نظام الفيصلين ومتوقع ان
تلحق ايضا بها جامعات اخرى خلال الايام
القادمه
طبعا التعليم العام حقيقه يحتاج الى زياده
جهد يعني عندنا الان عدد
الايام
هذه ايام عدد الايام الدراسيه الفعليه 180
يوم دراسي هذه
حقيقه اغلب دول العالم الدول العالميه
المتقدمه في التعليم لديها هذا العدد من
هذه هذا يعطي جوده للتع
ليم
العام المرحله الابتدائيه والمتوسطه
والثانوي بتعليم قوي بالمهارات لدينا
لدينا في العام القادم ان شاء الله في
العام
تعليم الموسيقى لدينا المس
رح لدينا يعني مهارات جديده فهذا يعطي
حقيقه فرصه ثلاث فصول دراسيه للتعليم
العام
انها تمكن الطلاب
وتطورهم بشكل كبير حتى يكونوا منافسين على
مستوى
شكرا جزيلا لك عبد اللطيف الحمادي
المستشار التربوي والتعليمي من الرياض
اشتراك في قناتنا على يوتيوب الضغط على زر
الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات